[Music]
patrice is with us uh in detroit hi
patrice how are you
hi dave it's an honor to speak with you
you too what's up um
okay well i have a distrust issue with
my
so-called financial advisor
when the market was up to 36 000 she and
i had our six-month
routine call and she had someone else on
the line but she did let me know and
what she was doing was without me
realizing it at that time was trying to
start i guess get him started with new
accounts
and advise me to take some of the money
that i had been saving for my down
payment toward getting into a home and
put it into investments well i already
have a 401k rollover with them
so
i feel like i was number one misadvised
and i'm not happy about it and i'm
looking to just move on before q3 rolls
around and i don't want to pay fees to
this firm and yet another firm i just
don't i don't trust them now
what do you advise me to do
i think i don't think you should ever
work with somebody you don't trust
especially on money so you need to move
it but then let me scold you also
you're like a grown woman and stuff
you made the decision
i know i owned that so you know you
didn't you blame them
um
and so you get you know the trust factor
has to come down to you
so we teach people not to use financial
advisors as babysitters but instead use
them as teachers
and so from now on the next time this
comes up your financial advisor's job is
to teach you and say you know if it was
me here's what i would do and why
and then based on that you
make your decision
and then it's your fault
okay
so you need to understand why they're
telling you to do this and then do it or
don't do it based on the why because you
have been taught and your incorrect
knowledge has increased and then you
decide when you're going to do it so
like patrice when i'm talking to these
nfl guys these little 23 year olds
and 24 year olds and they got 10 million
dollar signing bonus and they say i got
me a guy
that's somebody who's getting ready to
lose all their money
because some guy is going to tell them
what to do and they don't have a they
don't know their they you know they
don't know their butt from a hole in the
ground they're stuck and so they've got
it you have to go learn
you are in charge of your money
you have to take care of your money but
i would move it because i don't trust
him and then i would get an advisor in
my corner and i'm not going to have an
argument
with my financial advisor because they
don't they're not in charge of my money
i'm in charge of my money their job is
to teach me and then based on that
knowledge do i believe the knowledge and
am i going to buy it and then based on
that am i going to make a move
that's what you've got to get there but
you can't you can't you can't ever look
back on them again and say it was their
fault because from now on it's your
fault